there's a special bond between Elana
mazor and her seven-month-old
puppy he's from a litter that her
husband alexe found near the front line
and took care of just a few days before
he was
killed this puppy was my husband's
favorite she tells us and he helps me
cope with the loss a combat medic they
got married in March of this year and he
was killed in
June unfortunately there are some people
who act like the war is somewhere else
and not here they don't know what loss
is and don't understand the price we
pay this wall of Remembrance in keev is
a tribute to soldiers who have been
killed in the conflict since 2014 more
pictures have been added since the start
of this fullscale war especially in
recent months by families who want to
remember their loved ones the government
won't say how many Ukrainian soldiers
have died so far but it's thought to be
in the T of thousands and as this war
grinds on there'll be many more which
means thousands more widows at this art
therapy class war widows are able to
express their feelings on
canvas yenia paroma chose to paint
goldfish which were her husband's
passion when we visited like some zoo or
Botanical Garden there was like legs
with uh this kind of fishes he always
like had some moment self-meditation
this organization alone supports 2,500
widows and their
families we understand that no one will
replace such brave men and so for the
country it's a tragedy but someday the
war will end and women like us will be
needed to revive the country so we have
to be strong an unknown number of widows
but all dealing with incalculable loss
Rob McBride Al jazer
ke
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jaaz